ben what's next
thank you
next up
if you like drinking beers in the buff
check out this pub in england food and
wine reports a naturist aka nudist club
in the uk called nothing on events they
just had its first pub outing at the
royal oak in surrey
people were encouraged to gather on
natural for brews in the nude no shirt
no shoes
no problem
so this is a bar where people wait so a
nudist county is like let's all get
drunk together that's our thing
is that what it is
i think this is a no-go for me i'm sorry
but i'm not showing you my pale ale at
it's
this
happening
and also this is specifically at a bar
like i don't want to be nude anywhere in
public but i certainly don't want to be
nude and sitting on a bar
you know what i mean that's what i'm
saying it's like
oh you put a napkin down
[Laughter]
not for me
would you do it
no
no no i would not what if you knew there
was no cameras no one could ever record
it it's just you and
six of your co-hosts
well ironically listen i went to a
nightclub back in the day my friend um
john would do this comedy act he was
dick haney the world's worst comedian
and all he did was tell bad jokes and
there was this club called the blue
angel
and i decided to get naked and walk
around him and this was in the 90s so it
was cell phone free and you could get
away with stuff like that so i don't
judge it
but
now i could never
so i weirdly i mean i don't know i but i
listen i'm not judging i just couldn't
do it now no i've no judge either if you
guys want to go to this british pub with
your bangers and mash hanging out
yes
not
i love the idea that it exists i love
the idea that people are happy from it
well and it was because of that blue
angel story that david letterman's
producer somehow found out about it
through word because again there was no
internet no cell phones and that was the
story they asked me to tell which then
prompted me to get on letterman's desk
and do my thing so i don't know i say
that was due to that yes oh my goodness
yes and i had no idea what i was doing i
was just so wild and free so
you know
i don't know
maybe
wow
it could change a 180 immediately
i guess that's why i wanted to figure it
out you know different different strokes
different photos
i get it um all right well listen
clothes or nude bed shorts you are the
most amazing
[Applause]
i look like naked i look like uh beaker
from bunsen and beaker in the muppets
it's basically what i look like i don't
know beaker that well
well i would statler and waldorf that
anytime and do commentary all right
appreciate it um ben you are the
greatest sonic the hedgehog 2 is in
theaters everywhere i went with my kids
we had the best time it's such a good
movie there will be a third and i'm
happy that you broke records with it
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
you